[Music]
the premise of the movie is set in a
dystopian future after a mysterious
virus killed most of the earth's
population less than two million
survivors are left as a side effect of
the virus all humans on earth are
blinded alongside the children born
after the plague time passes and sight
becomes a myth something only heavenly
creatures are capable of over time other
human senses like smell and hearing are
heightened which help people survive
without the sense of sight but the world
goes into the medieval period again and
no technology exists in some rare cases
a few people are believed to be sighted
but they are declared a witch and killed
in the city of kenzua lives the queen
named kane she is the leader of the
witch finder army and the overseer of
the entire city that is set over a dam
the queen is extremely religious and
thinks that every human who can see is
defying god's wish she exercises her
power ruthlessly and murders anyone who
spreads heresy about the sense of sight
then we are introduced to the alchemy
tribe settled in the middle of a vast
jungle the leader of the tribe is a
fearless warrior baba voss baba's wife
magra is going into labor and is being
helped by an elder member of the tribe
named paris megra cries in pain asking
for her husband but he cannot be with
her because of a more important job
typical baba the tribe is about to be
attacked by the witch finder who thinks
magura is a witch anyone who comes in
their way will also be murdered but the
people are ready to fight with their
lives for their leader's wife although
the entire tribe lacks the sense of
sight they have mastered their hearing
and other senses the experienced members
of the tribe predict that around 200
witch finder soldiers are rapidly making
their way towards them and seem to be
armed with dangerous weapons baba
announces that he will protect his tribe
and encourages the others to do the same
before blowing the war horn
they perform a traditional dance for
good luck and start preparing themselves
somewhere else the general of the witch
finder army tamakhti is with a man named
bax he is also a tribe member of valkeni
but has a conflict with baba hence he is
helping the enemy to kill magra and
teach baba a lesson bax reveals that
magra is not an ordinary woman last
winter she came to the tribe pregnant
and wounded claiming that she had walked
through a snowstorm baba took her in as
his wife and decided to adopt her child
ever since then she has been living with
the tribe but bax doesn't like the fact
that baba gets to do whatever he wants
he then gives the general a necklace
that has the name of the man who
impregnated magra on touching it the
general freezes in shock the necklace
has the name jerila morrell who is said
to be the only person with vision the
general has been working for years to
kill jerila morel under the orders of
the queen herself if magura is present
with his child this means they are near
to finding him as well being so close to
his lifelong goal excites the general
and he asks bax to reveal the security
measures of his tribe somewhere else
magra gives birth to a child and
realizes she has another one inside her
body paris does a c-section and
eventually a boy and a girl are born in
the border of the woods a wall of stone
has been built for the tribe's
protection they use it as a shield and
initiate the fight killing many rivals
when they are about to be overpowered
the wall is broken and the stones fall
down the hill crushing half of the witch
witchfinder soldiers after everything
calms down baba senses that the other
half is still at the riverbank they will
attack after a storm passes so the tribe
has only a few hours to prepare baba
meets his children for the first time
but is troubled about their future they
know that fighting the rest of the army
will not be easy to avoid any more loss
of lives paris suggests they run away
through a secret bridge that most people
don't know about everyone agrees and
makes their way to the bridge under her
leadership when they're halfway through
the general and his army arrive
initially they do not comprehend where
the villagers are but they soon sense
the presence of the secret bridge and
push backs into it baba reaches the
other end and cuts the bridge after
saving backs since he is still a member
of the tribe with the pathway gone the
tribe runs away and the general fails
once again an eagle brings the message
of failure to the queen she goes to the
temple and tells the council about the
message they received it turns out that
jere la morale killed her sister long
ago which is why she wants him dead at
all costs moreover to her and her people
someone with sight is a demon knowing
that two of jayla morel's children have
been born the queen sends another army
of witchfinders to help the troop kill
all three of them
somewhere else the tribe comes to a halt
and magra tells everyone about jerila
morel she reveals that the rumors are
true and he indeed has been blessed with
the power of vision he doesn't believe
in religion and thinks that vision will
help make the world a better place not
the other way around he has also told
magra about a safe place in the middle
of the mountains which will never be
found because it is like a maze magra
takes everyone to the place where they
decide to settle down in the following
scene baba goes out on a walk with both
his children this is when we find out
that they have also been blessed with
the power of vision a while later he
goes into the woods to look for food
with his children when they are suddenly
attacked by a bear he tries killing it
multiple times but it only works when an
arrow hits the animal the person who
fired the arrow is none other than
jeremiah himself he is glad that his
children are in safe hands because he
has a lot of things to do before being a
father to them
classic jerila morale he tells baba
about the box he can find near a
waterfall he also hands baba a key to
the box and says that the children must
be given the box when they reach the age
of 12. he suggests they name the boy
coffin and the girl haniwa but before
saying what the box contains he runs
away the betrayer bax is also in the
woods and hears baba shout jeremiarel's
name he suspects something is wrong and
tells his aunt about it bax's parents
were killed because of a punishment at
baba's order so his entire family is
against him they hire a girl named
shadow to find out what is going on
shadow is a tribe member who is known
for being invisible she is so good at
hiding herself that she has never been
noticed by anyone in the tribe even
though she lives with them oh i felt
that at night magra baba and paris open
gerla morel's box where he has left a
toy boat and many books that can teach
the children to read the group realizes
the children can see but decide to keep
it a secret paris predicts that the
books contain knowledge about the
ancient people and their technologies
when the children are ready they will
one day have to go on their own journey
to establish a new world system magra is
extremely against the idea she orders
them to bury the box outside the village
and never talk about it again the
children should be kept away from it at
all costs just then paris realizes that
they are being spied on and discontinues
the conversation outside shadow lies to
backs telling him that baba was playing
with his kids inside his hut and nothing
else bax also figures it out and makes a
plan of his own he sends a message on a
bottle into the river and decides to do
it every day until the general finds one
of the bottles and lands an attack on
baba meanwhile the general and his
troops are doing everything in their
power to look for the tribe they burn
several houses and kill many people
asking them about magra however even
after years of searching they are
unsuccessful in locating her in the dam
the queen gets a message from the
general saying that he wants to return
home however on checking the message
closely she discovers that it has been
tampered with upon further investigation
she finds out the people of the kingdom
are not satisfied with her rule the
dam's condition is getting weaker and
instead of thinking for her people she
is more focused on catching witches
which are of no concern to the kingdom
hence two members of the council changed
the message and are planning to have her
killed later that day she kills the
council members by hanging them from the
ceiling and burning them with
electricity then we are shown a montage
of coffin and hanewa growing up they
keep their sight a secret but continue
watching the tribe and its ritual in
ways that no one has eventually 12 years
pass and the time comes when they are
supposed to be introduced to books paris
wants to follow jarela morel's orders
but magra is strictly against it she
wants her children to live a normal life
and be happy rather than go into a war
with the entire world paris understands
her concern but knows that her feelings
as a mother cannot come in the way of a
better world hence at night she secretly
asks the kids to come to her hut and
gives them the books their father left
for them initially they refused to go
against their mother and run away but
then they discussed the topic for a
while and come to a conclusion to try to
read the books baba hears them talking
from outside but decides to allow them
to take their own path he tells paris
about the kids and they plan to keep the
books a secret from magra knowing that
she would burn them all if she found out
in the following few months the children
hide from their mother every day to
learn the alphabet ultimately they are
able to read sentences and literature
which provides them with the knowledge
of the past in the following scene we
see a girl from a village get her hands
on a bottle by the bank of a river it is
one of the bottles with the message that
backs left for the general after
conducting a years-long search for
jailer morel and failing miserably the
general finally returns home to the dam
he kneels down before the queen and
tells her that he has brought a hundred
horses several kilos of grains and many
more things necessary for the people of
the kingdom however he has failed to
bring the one person he was sent to
capture he is ready to face the
consequences and be punished with death
but his last wish is to commit the
unthinkable because he wants to be
remembered as a warrior not as a fool
who couldn't complete a royal order the
queen agrees and sends him to jump off
the dam a while later the note sent by
bax is brought to the queen and she
finds out about the children's
whereabouts when the general is seconds
away from committing the unthinkable she
stops him and shows him the message the
win is so overwhelming for the queen
that she breaks down crying in his arms
back in the village haniwa and coffin
hear a horn calling everyone to gather
for a meeting it turns out that an
incestuous relationship between bax and
his aunt has resulted in the birth of a
disfigured and stillborn child everyone
is horrified by the incident but this
shines a light on a more important
problem incest isn't cool also the
tribe's population is low which means
people have started maintaining
relationships with their relatives paris
thinks that they should start
socializing with other tribes by going
to their festivals baba is skeptical
because they have to stay hidden however
when the entire village takes paris side
he has no option but to agree alright
fine guys let's go get laid he asks his
children to stay home and the villagers
to never tell a soul about their past
this is all they can do to protect their
homes from the witch finders after baba
magra and the rest of the villagers
leave to take part in a tribe's festival
we see coffin and hanawa following them
closely behind they stop at night when
they reach a market-like place where a
crowd has gathered to witness the fire
festival it is then revealed that the
festival is to celebrate the death of
sighted monsters many blind people who
have been falsely accused of being
sighted are tied to a bonfire a priest
declares them to be monsters and lights
them on fire haniwa tries to tell them
that they're wrong but coffin stops her
scared of their truth being outed they
watch as people gather around the fire
dancing and making love paris and magra
are also shocked at the brutal
punishment paris claims that although
they are protected from the witch
finders the queen's principle is
spreading rapidly turning people into
monsters unable to watch the ritual
anymore coffin walks away from the crowd
when no one is around he is approached
by slave traders who abduct him and take
him away not just coffin but the slaves
have kidnapped many children from
several tribes haniwa finds her brother
missing and quickly goes to tell her
parents a search party sets out to look
for him consisting of baba magra paris
haniwa and many more in the meantime the
slave traders have tied the children's
hands and mouths and are following a
cloud of smoke to a different town an
hour later they reach a building where
the slaves hands are untied and they are
kept on the ground the search party
comes across a recently burnt piece of
wood and assumes that the traders were
here some time ago there is no way for
them to be sure until haniwa notices her
brother's writing on a rock he has asked
them to follow the signs to get to him
when haniwa tells everyone about the
sign magra is shocked she inquires how
haniwa knows what he wrote and
eventually finds out that her children
know how to read they have followed in
their father's footsteps and are
planning to do the same in the future
magra fumes in rage wanting her children
to be dumb and useless i guess but her
priority is to look for her son the
rescue group also reaches the building
where the slaves are kept baba tells
everyone to stay outside while he goes
in alone haniwa argues that she wants to
join him but baba doesn't want her to
see what he will become in front of his
enemies he has spent the first half of
his life in similar circumstances
killing many people but he doesn't want
his daughter to see him like that he
then attacks the guard and quietly
brings him to the place where the slaves
are kept cough and sees them and makes a
noise to alert his father of the
presence
as baba hears it he turns into a beast
and kills all the traitors one after
another by the end of the fight his own
son can hardly recognize him at last
baba catches the leader of the gang and
stabs him in his throat damn aquaman
just went dark coffin finally meets his
mother who hugs him at first but then
pushes him away for hiding such a huge
part of their lives from her when they
reach the village the children apologize
to their mother and reveal that they
have to travel far away someday
according to books that they have been
given an emotional magra hugs them
finally coming to terms that they are
their own people outside baba hears a
dog barking and realizes that they are
being approached by the enemy then we
see the general and his army arrive at
the village at the same time magra
brings out a tiny pouch that has
something important inside it but before
she can hand it to her children the news
about the attack spreads in the tribe
back starts telling everyone to hand
magra over to the enemies to save their
lives an enraged coffin takes advantage
of the situation and holds backs hostage
using him he and his family manage to
run away from the village they are
followed by shadow who wants to join
them in the journey when the family is
far enough haniwa wants to kill bax for
everything he did however coffin lets
him free to prove that they are not the
monster that people paint them as after
everyone walks away bax yet again
returns to the village and tells the
general about the escapees the army
holds the entire village at knife point
declaring that until the real coffin and
haniwa are found they are all witches
somewhere else baba and the family reach
a riverbank and get on a boat he made
over the years just when they are about
to sail they are surrounded by the enemy
the general announces that he has spent
his entire life looking for jailer
morel's children and is not going to
back down now that they are so close he
also threatens to kill the entire
village if they put up a fight or refuse
to come with him the rival soldiers get
into the water and close on the boat
when they are close enough baba kills a
man which makes the others find out
their exact location this gives rise to
a battle between the two parties in the
middle of the fight haniwa shoots an
arrow at backs and kills him baba
manages to row the boat further away
where the water is deep since the army
doesn't have a boat they yet again lose
the family the general kills backs to
protect him from suffering further and
orders a commander to kill everyone in
the tribe paris who is also on the boat
shows everyone a map left by jayla morel
for his children they have two options
either to follow the map and go along
the river or to take a path along the
forest and go to a safe place they take
a vote and decide to follow
jeremiarell's map magra is not happy
about the decision but has no room to
argue no one listens to magra a while
later they stop at the bank to take a
rest for the night back in the kingdom
the queen finds out about baba and his
family escaping one more time the
council members request that she focus
on the kingdom because it needs more
care than her religious beliefs it is
then revealed that the queen used to be
in love with jayla morrell long ago but
he didn't reciprocate the feeling i
wonder how many horrible decisions were
made by leaders in the past because they
were butthurt or got cocked the people
think they are being ruled by a lovesick
queen who only thinks of herself they
have lost people and treasures because
of her ego and are vocal about it as
well the queen abruptly leaves the
meeting and later assassinates the
council members who were opposing her
earlier the following morning baba and
the group wake up to their belongings
missing even the pouch that was close to
magura has disappeared as they try to
look for them coffin notices someone
standing a few yards away somewhere else
the queen is told that the people are
protesting for her to be removed from
the throne there is no one on her side
and she is bound to be punished for the
deaths she caused enraged by their
audacity the queen makes the decision to
end the entire kingdom and look for
jarla morel on her own she closes the
dam which destabilizes it causing it to
move aggressively as it starts to flood
and break she runs away in a carriage
with her dog and her close assistant the
people of the kingdom are left to die
to see what happens next watch the
second part in series recap